Bonjour! Chez Chroniques de Prof, on aime
la nature. On vous a déjà parlé de l'histoire
des forêts, de la mer, mais il est un thème
qui n'avait pas encore été abordé ici.
-Les déserts.
-La montagne.
-Qui est un désert.
-C'est pas faux. La plupart des hautes montagnes
sont vides, de nos jours moins de 0,18% de
la population mondiale vit au dessus de 3500m
soit environ dix millions de personnes. Bon
l'exemple est un peu extrême, mais si on
élargit un peu: moins de 8% de la population
mondiale vit au dessus de 1000m. Là, ça
calme. Qu'en était-il dans les temps reculés?
Que pensaient les hommes des montagnes qui
les entouraient? Comment y vivaient-ils?
Une enquête signée la Prof.
-Et moi.
-Et elles.
Pour cet épisode on parlera surtout des montagnes
françaises, non par chauvinisme mais parce
que je suis surtout une historienne française
spécialisée dans l'histoire française.
-Elle est historienne, Defrance.
-Les Alpes, surtout, sont un massif particulièrement
étudié qui reviendra fréquemment.
Bref, la montagne est fréquentée depuis:
longtemps. Les hommes de Neandertal se baladaient
sur les versants des Alpes il y a des dizaines
de milliers d'années, pour la chasse, et
la présence humaine laisse des traces plus
importantes à partir de -10 000.
Ce n'est qu'au néolithique que commence l'exploitation
des montagnes: dans le massif vosgien par
exemple, les défrichements commencent vers
-5000 et progressent à l'âge de Bronze,
à partir de -2000. Les hommes s'installent
dans les fonds de vallée, pratiquent l'élevage
et exploitent les ressources minérales des
montagnes: les pierres qui servent à la
fabrication de différents outils, et le cuivre.
Les hommes du néolithique sont donc éleveurs,
mineurs, et commerçants: les grands cols
alpins sont déjà des voies de passage qui
facilitent les échanges.
L'occupation romaine, à partir du Ier siècle
avant J.C., ne modifie pas vraiment les villages
déjà bien développés mais permet de renforcer
le réseau routier. Dans les Vosges, par exemple,
le massif est traversé par cinq routes à
partir de la conquête romaine.
-Elle entraîne aussi le développement de
la viticulture sur les pentes, car il est
bien connu que les romains et les romaines
adorent la picole.
-Nous apprécions aussi les fromages et produits
laitiers que ces montagnards nous vendent.
Pour accompagner le vin.
-Mais la culture montagnarde reste celte,
voire pré-celte, et avec les crises de la
fin de l'empire romain celles-ci deviennent
des lieux de refuge et de résistance. Les
populations des Alpes, surtout, deviennent
mouvantes jusqu'à la christianisation de
la région au VIe siècle. Mais là on arrive
au Moyen Âge, et avant ça on va faire un
petit point mythologie.
J'avais déjà un peu abordé le sujet dans
mon épisode sur les superstitions, mais les
lieux désertiques sont particulièrement
riches en croyances et légendes. Les montagnes
ne font pas exception, ce qui explique le
rapport particulier que les humains entretiennent
avec elles. Depuis l'Antiquité grecque au
moins, on attribue aux montagnes de nombreuses
légendes sur les origines des avalanches,
des brouillards et autres phénomènes naturels
qui éveillent forcément les soupçons.
D'autres histoires renforcent ces croyances
au Moyen Âge: celle des démons qui vivent
sur le mont Aiguille, dans le Vercors, ou
celles de sabbats de sorcières sur les sommets.
-Voir notre épisode 14 sur le sujet!
-Ce type de légende fait des sommets des
lieux inquiétants, répulsifs, aux formes
étranges et immenses, qu'on se contente de
traverser par nécessité. Les descriptions
des voyageurs, marchands, pèlerins, sont
souvent négatives. Dans leurs récits on
retrouve des informations sur les routes,
le dénivelé, les distances, mais ils s'attardent
peu sur la beauté des paysages. C'est le
cas de Félix Fabri, qui raconte son voyage
à travers les Alpes au XVe siècle:
«Nous sommes arrivés dans un certain endroit
par un très mauvais chemin, défoncé par
la glace, la neige et les pierres, où la
route royale avait été totalement arrachée
par des amas de neige et de glaces. En effet,
il était tombé la veille du haut de la montagne
des blocs de neige qui avaient entraîné
avec eux de grosses pierres et des arbres
retournés jusqu’aux racines, et le passage
n’était pas rouvert. Nous avons fait la
traversée avec grande peine.»
-Il est vrai que les voyageurs passent par
les contrées les plus reculées, tandis que
les habitants des Alpes vivent en des lieux
plus propices et savent mieux aborder la montagne.
-On retrouve cette distinction entre la montagne
vivable, exploitable, et l'ailleurs que constituent
les sommets dans les descriptions de notaires.
Ils y détaillent parfaitement les prairies,
ruisseaux et cabanes d'alpages, mais ne parlent
jamais des sommets qui sont d'ailleurs encore
peu nommés avant le XVIIe siècle.
Les habitants des montagnes ont eu aussi leur
lot de légendes et d'idées reçues, décrits
comme des gens frustres, fous, blasphémateurs...
-Alors qu'ils sont souvent en très bons termes
avec les habitants des vallées.
-Ils n'ont même pas un mode de vie si différent
de leurs contemporains de plaines, on ne peut
pas vraiment parler de «mode de vie»
montagnard. Cette vision négative s'explique
par le climat rude, qui incline les voyageurs
à faire des montagnards le reflet de leur
environnement.
-La montagne est sauvage, donc les montagnards
le sont aussi.
-En plus, ces voyageurs sont souvent amenés
à traverser différentes aires linguistiques
en franchissant les Alpes ou les Pyrénées,
et ça, c'est perturbant! Imaginez un peu!
Des gens qui ne parlent pas notre langue sont
forcément des sauvages!
Paradoxalement, les montagnes sont aussi dans
de nombreuses religions des intermédiaires
entre les hommes et les dieux. On peut citer
par exemple le mont Olympe ou le Sinaï. Plusieurs
auteurs du Moyen Âge tentent de situer le
Paradis sur une montagne d'Orient, dans les
monts d'Arménie ou sur l'Atlas. Il n'est
pas étonnant qu'elles deviennent alors des
lieux de refuge, de nombreux ermites choisissant
de s'y installer ou d'y construire des chapelles
ou des croix. Celles-ci ont pour fonction
de christianiser le lieu, et d'en chasser
toutes les créatures fantastiques qui pourraient
y vivre. Un exemplum du milieu du xiiiesiècle
résume le rôle de ces croix: «Dans
le diocèse de Tarentaise, au-dessus du château
de Chevron, il était une roche très haute
qui n’avait jamais pu être gravie tant
elle était abrupte. Là, se tenaient fréquemment
des assemblées de démons et autres fantasmagories;
de partout, on voyait des feux s’allumer,
des flammes vaciller et des châteaux se construire
tout seuls. Les gens du lieu tinrent conseil
pour savoir ce qu’il convenait de faire.
Ils gravirent la montagne, posèrent des croix
de bois au sommet. Depuis lors, aucun démon
ni aucune de ces lueurs n’apparurent plus
à cet endroit.»
-Avec le développement de la littérature
merveilleuse, au bas Moyen Âge, les montagnes
seraient aussi le refuge de créatures magiques
telles que des griffons, des dragons ou des
nains, vivant dans le creux des montagnes.
-D'autres pensent que le cristal est de la
neige de montagne solidifiée, ou que les
torrents charrient de l'or et des pierres
précieuses.
-Un autre groupe de légendes que j'aime beaucoup
parle des rois dormants, des rois cachés
sous la montagne qui attendraient pendant
des centaines d'années avant de réapparaître
au moment où on a besoin d'eux. Tels des
messies. On y retrouve le roi Arthur, dormant
bien au chaud dans un volcan en Sicile, mais
aussi l'empereur Frédéric II qui se cacherait
encore dans les monts de Thuringe deux cent
ans après sa mort, ou encore le roi de Bohême
Venceslas II.
-Il arriverait aussi que des voyageurs se
retrouvent, au détour d'un col, dans des
mondes parallèles dirigés par le roi Arthur
en personne!
-On peut noter que le nom d'Arthur vient du
grec arctos, qui signifie ours, et où vivent
les ours si ce n'est dans des cavernes montagnardes?
-Sur la banquise, nous en savons quelque chose.
-Chut, pas de mauvais souvenirs ici.
-Time Warp.
-La vision des montagnes commence à changer
au XIVe siècle, à une époque où le peuplement
et le trafic en montagne s'intensifient. Les
premières ascensions de sommets permettent
également une redécouverte de la montagne,
notamment celle de Pétrarque qui aurait escaladé
le mont Ventoux en 1336. Que son récit soit
vrai ou faux, il est l'un des premiers à
décrire la montagne de manière positive,
avec intérêt et curiosité. Une autre ascension
importante est celle du mont Aiguille en 1492,
sur l'ordre du roi Charles VIII.
-Un gros coup de com, qui visait à montrer
que ce mont inaccessible ne l'était pas tant
que ça.
-La montagne commence à être regardée pour
elle-même, pour sa beauté, une vision qui
se développe au cours de l'époque moderne.
Mais on reviendra là-dessus en fin d'épisode.
Une certaines vision scientifique des montagnes
existe aussi au Moyen Âge: Barthélémy
l'Anglais étudie la présence des mines en
montagne, Jean de Mandeville s'intéresse
au climat particulier des sommets, Vincent
de Beauvais met en avant l'air pur qui fait
des montagnards des gens sains et forts...
Par ce qu'il ne faut pas oublier que les montagnes
sont des lieux de vie particuliers. José
de Acosta écrit au XVIe siècle que les voyageurs
qui s'aventurent à haute altitude souffrent
de troubles sérieux. Ces troubles sont le
«mal des montagnes», un manque d'oxygène
pouvant mener à la mort.
-Il est causé par la faible pression qui
entraîne une raréfaction de l'oxygène en
montagne, l'augmentation du rayonnement solaire,
les fortes différences de température sur
une journée...
-Bien que cela ne concerne pas vraiment l'Europe,
au dessus de 2500m les populations montagnardes
ont connu au fil des générations une adaptation
biologique qui les empêche de ressentir ce
mal des montagnes. Au Tibet, dans les Andes,
les habitants se sont adaptés à l'altitude
au point de souffrir parfois d'un excès d'adaptation
qui les empêche de se fixer définitivement
dans les plaines. Pour pallier à cela les
rois incas du Cusco envoyaient leurs troupes
en garnison sur la côte par roulement de
deux mois, avant de les ramener prendre des
forces dans les montagnes.
Revenons-en maintenant au VIe siècle, où
on avait laissé nos villageois montagnards.
On sait maintenant que les montagnes françaises
sont occupées depuis bien longtemps, et s'il
vous en manquait encore des preuves on retrouve
dans les noms de villages des empreintes préceltiques,
celtiques, latins, franciques et médiévaux.
À partir du VIe siècle, les premières abbayes
s'installent dans les montagnes: l'abbaye
de Saint Gall, par exemple, fondée en 613.
Entre le VIe et le XIIe siècle, les massifs
français se couvrent d'abbayes fondées à
l'initiative de grands seigneurs. Il ne faut
pas en conclure pour autant que les moines
sont les grands défricheurs des montagnes:
ils exploitent leurs terres certes, mais leur
principale utilité est d'attirer des populations
laïques sur ces terres, des colons qui mettent
en valeur la terre, bâtissent des villages,
créent des alpages...
Les nouveaux villages construits au Moyen
Âge sont donc souvent crées par des paysans
sur l'initiative de seigneurs, laïcs ou religieux.
En cela, rien de différent avec les villages
des plaines.
-Les monastères contribuent aussi au développement
de la transhumance, au Xe siècle. Et ils
développent la fabrication du fromage.
-On peut prendre l'exemple de l'abbaye de
Saint-Michel-de-la-Cluse, qui reçoit du comte
de Genève la vallée de Chamonix vers l'an
1090. Elle est déjà un peu habitée et cultivée,
mais surtout occupée par des glaciers qui
commencent seulement à reculer, car l'Europe
connaît alors un petit réchauffement climatique.
Les habitants vivent donc en fond de vallée.
L'abbaye décide de créer un prieuré et
sa seigneurie à Chamonix, achève de faire
défricher le fond de vallée, puis fait créer
par les paysans des alpages sur les pentes
des montagnes à partir du XIIIe siècle.
Vers 1350, la vallée de Chamonix et ses montagnes
sont largement humanisées.
Le peuplement des montagnes consiste en de
nombreux hameaux plus ou moins dispersés,
fédérés autour d'un chef-lieu parfois pas
plus gros que les autres. La plupart de ces
hameaux s'implantent sur les fonds de vallée,
qui sont plats et permettent donc mieux l'agriculture,
ou sur les versants orientés au sud, car
l'ensoleillement y est maximal. Les villages
de montagne, très étendus, sont donc divisés
entre le fonds de vallée et le bas des versants
où se trouvent les habitations permanentes
et quelques prairies, les milieux de versants
composés de prairies et de forêts, et les
sommets où se créent les alpages. Ce type
d'étagement est décrit au XVe siècle par
un religieux de la chartreuse du Reposoir:
«Le lieu admirable où se rendit le saint
homme est une vallée profonde, située entre
des montagnes. [...] Elle est tout à fait
impropre à la plantation d’arbres fruitiers,
et insuffisamment fertile. Au milieu s’écoule
une rivière, entourée d’une plaine étroite.
C’est là que sont bâties les maisons.
Tout autour, s’élèvent des monts surmontés
de rochers très élevés. Ils sont recouverts
de bois de pins et d’autres espèces, mais
au sommet on trouve de toutes parts des pâturages
qui sont excellents pour la nourriture du
bétail.» Un joli paysage de montagne,
donc, crée par l'homme.
Les maisons montagnardes sont bien des maisons,
le terme de «chalet» ne désigne que
des bâtiments d'alpage jusqu'au développement
du tourisme en montagne. Ces maisons sont
souvent construites sur deux ou trois étages,
dont le premier niveau est en pierre et le
reste en bois. Elles servent à la fois d'habitation
pour les hommes, souvent au niveau intermédiaire,
d'étable pour les animaux au niveau inférieur,
et de grange pour le foin au dernier étage.
-Un cellier, servant à la conservation du
fromage, est aussi intégré à la maison.
-Attendez, pourquoi on a pas une pièce à
fromage, nous?
-Nous avons déjà ta chambre.
-Les bâtiments d'alpage sont très nombreux
mais moins bien connus. Le principal sert
au logement des hommes et à la fabrication
de fromage, et se nomme cabanna ou chavanna
selon les lieux. Il y a aussi des granges
en bois où le foin est mis à sécher jusqu'à
l'automne ou l'hiver, où il sera descendu
sur des luges, quand la grange de la maison
principale sera vidée.
-On y trouve aussi des abris pour les bêtes
et des prairies intermédiaires.
-Et à proximité des vignes sont construits
de petits bâtiments rassemblant les instruments
nécessaires à la viticulture.
-Et puis, vivre à la montagne comporte quelques
spécificités. Et quand je dis spécificités,
je parle de contraintes et de risques.
-La neige, dans une société où ne connaît
ni les raquettes ni les skis, ce n'est pas
très pratique.
-Parfois la neige prend la forme d'avalanches,
entraînant les maisons avec elles.
Dans les zones à risque on remarque que l'habitat
est beaucoup plus resserré, pour justement
éviter de construire sur les couloirs d'avalanches
connus. Certains villages conservent aussi
un manteau forestier au dessus des maisons
pour freiner la neige ou les glissements de
terrain.
-En fond de vallée, les torrents peuvent
entrer en crue et pas mal amocher les villages,
aussi.
-Et de manière moins dramatique, la pente
et les distances représentent des contraintes
pour les montagnards. Le relief isole les
hameaux les uns des autres, les cols sont
parfois difficilement franchissables et supposent
l'entretien de routes et de ponts. La pente
présente certains avantages, quand il s'agit
de descendre le foin et les troncs à la luge,
mais réduit aussi l'espace cultivable et
habitable.
-Dans certaines vallées des Alpes les paysans
doivent s'encorder pour faucher les prés.
-Malgré leur isolement, les communautés
alpines présentent de nombreuses formes de
solidarité. Avant même l'existence des seigneuries
et des paroisses, les villageois, il existe
des groupes informels: les «voisins»,
les «hommes de», des groupes représentés
par des chefs de famille et qui se réunissent
dans le cadre de leur hameau. On en trouve
des mentions à partir du XIe siècle, mais
ils existent probablement depuis plus longtemps.
Les liens du village passent aussi par le
mariage: ce n'est pas une exception montagnarde,
on se marie surtout dans le hameau ou dans
ceux d'à côté.
Les communautés villageoises naissent réellement
en réaction au développement des seigneuries:
face au seigneur, les paysans demandent une
mise par écrit de leurs libertés sous la
forme de chartes de franchise. Celles-ci réglementent
l'accès aux alpages, l'entretien des chemins
et des communs... Certaines communautés peuvent
regrouper plusieurs hameaux, plusieurs paroisses,
et elles n'ont pas non plus les même pouvoirs.
Il y en a qui organisent des réunion périodiques,
d'autres disposent de magistrats et assemblées
permanentes qu'on appelle consulats...
-D'autres enfin sont carrément des communautés
de vallée qui regroupent plusieurs dizaines
de villages, se rassemblant plusieurs fois
dans l'année sous la supervision du seigneur
et ayant même certaines fonctions judiciaires.
-Au XIIIe siècle les grands seigneurs s'impliquent
davantage dans leurs terres montagnardes.
Ils introduisent dans les petites seigneuries
de montagne leurs propres vassaux et font
également appel à la population locale pour
faire office de fonctionnaires. Il peut s'agir
de petits nobles locaux ou surtout de notables
de village, des notaires ou paysans aisés
par exemple. Les zones de montagne restent
souvent des zones frontalières, qu'il faut
donc bien maîtriser.
-Une autre communauté importante est la paroisse,
qui présente la particularité d'être très
étendue en montagne. Elle est aussi plus
récente: alors que la plupart des paroisses
en Europe sont créées entre le Xe et le
XIIIe siècle, dans les montagnes leur création
continue jusqu'au XVe siècle. Du fait des
risques d'incendies et d'avalanches, l'église
et le cimetière servent souvent de lieu de
stockage, ce qui ne plaît pas trop aux évêques.
L'église peut cependant être difficile d'accès
en hiver, du fait de l'éloignement entre
les hameaux et le village: à cause de cela
certains diocèse au XIIIe siècle autorisent
les parents à baptiser eux-même leur enfant.
Malgré toutes ces marques de solidarité,
il existe aussi de grosses concurrences entre
communautés. -A mon époque, une pratique
courante est de voler les bêtes du hameau
d'à côté et de le manger tous ensemble,
comme un rite. On appelle ça «moutonner
l'aver» ou «pignorer le bétail».
Du XIe au XIVe siècle, la montagne s'humanise
donc de plus en plus, mais il reste un défi:
de quoi vit-on sur les sommets?
La base de l'économie et surtout de la survie,
c'est l'agriculture. Pour ça, les montagnes
sont pas l'idéal: l'agriculture montagnarde
est avant tout vivrière, les paysans doivent
faire face au risque de gel qui peut survenir
toute l'année au dessus de 1500m et aux chutes
de neige précoces ou tardives. Les moissons
peuvent parfois être repoussées jusqu'à
la Toussaint, et les semailles sont donc décalées
d'un an ou remplacées par des céréales
de printemps moins bonnes à faire du pain.
De plus les sols sont de mauvaise qualité,
et de nombreuses céréales ne poussent pas
au delà d'une certaine altitude.
Les habitants de Cervières témoignent de
la situation en 1434: «Notre territoire
est stérile, très montagneux et situé en
un lieu mauvais et dangereux. Nous y récoltons
trop peu de blé et de foin pour assurer notre
subsistance, à l’exception de quatre ou
cinq d’entre nous. Nous sommes obligés
chaque année d’acheter du blé.» Les
champs et prés sont très dispersés et étroits,
les habitants profitent du moindre espace
possible malgré la pente. On cultive surtout
le seigle, l'orge, l'avoine, le sarrasin à
partir du XVe siècle, et on plante quelques
vergers et vignes.
-Pour le vin!
-Les difficultés de l'agriculture rendent
l'élevage indispensable, pour fumer les terres
et accompagner ses céréales de produits
laitiers. La plupart des paysans possèdent
donc quelques vaches, moutons ou brebis.
D'autres ressources locales sont exploitées:
le bois, d'abord, est souvent employé et
réemployé dans la construction. Les forêts
servent aussi au chauffage, à la cueillette
de la mousse, des fruits et des pommes de
pin, à la confection du charbon de bois et
de produits d'artisanat... Le bois coupé
est exporté des montagnes vers la vallée
par flottage, comme j'en avais déjà parlé
dans ma vidéo sur les forêts.
-Chroniques de Prof numéro 27!
-L'eau des torrents est canalisée, on est
loin des barrages hydro-électriques, mais
les moulins à eau et forges hydrauliques
se multiplient sur les rivières pyrénéennes
et alpines au XIVe siècle. Les ruisseaux
permettent aussi l'irrigation, ou constituent
des étangs pour la pisciculture. La pêche,
bien que contrôlée par le seigneur, constitue
une alimentation d'appoint pour les montagnards
qui en ont le droit.
Enfin, la roche est exploitée pour la construction
des maisons et des églises. On trouve aussi
dans les montagnes des carrières d'argile
et quelques mines de fer, de plomb, d'argent
ou d'or attestées dès le XIIe siècle.
Quand on pense aux montagnes, on pense beaucoup
à la transhumance, cette migration des sommets
vers les vallées ou des vallées vers les
sommets pour faire pâturer le bétail. La
plupart des éleveurs ne possèdent que quelques
bêtes, comme je le disais plus tôt, et font
donc la transhumance avec leurs animaux, en
famille, dans de petits chalets où ils fabriquent
directement leur fromage. Une partie de la
famille reste en bas pour s'occuper des champs
et des prés.
-On appelle cette pratique la «petite montagne».
-La «grande montagne» consiste alors
à rassembler les troupeaux du hameau et à
les confier à un alpagiste, un berger. Le
lait est aussi mis en commun et transformé
en fromage dans un chalet collectif, tandis
que les propriétaires des troupeaux restent
dans la vallée et s'occupent des moissons
tranquillement. Le berger a l'interdiction
de quitter la montagne avant la fin de la
mission, et doit dédommager le propriétaire
pour tout animal perdu.
Toutes ces exploitations, notamment l'élevage,
ouvrent les habitants des montagnes au commerce
et permettent à certaines familles de s'enrichir.
Comme je le disais plus tôt, les montagnes
sont parcourues au moins dès le IXe siècle
par des pèlerins en route vers Rome ou Jérusalem,
mais aussi par des marchands qui transitent
entre les foires de Champagne, d'Allemagne
et d'Italie, surtout à partir du XIIIe siècle.
Le péage de Jougne, dans le Doubs, enregistre
un passage tous les deux jours en 1340.
-Le transport des marchandises est coûteux
à cause de ces péages et de quelques coins
à brigands, mais moins risqué que par la
mer.
-Certains montagnards participent à ce commerce
européen en se faisant guides de montagne,
transporteurs, ou en commerçant eux-même.
-À Barcelonnette, par exemple, les habitants
pratiquent du XIVe au XIXe siècle le marchandage
saisonnier, d'octobre à avril. Ils font la
tournée des villages avec leur marchandise
à dos d'âne ou d'homme et vendent des tissus,
principalement. Ce sont les colporteurs, dont
les enfants imitent le métier en se faisant
montreurs de marmottes ou joueurs de vielle
dans les villages.
D'autres paysans vendent le produit de leur
élevage sur les foires, qui se tiennent de
plus en plus haut en montagne à la fin du
XIIIe siècle. On en trouve une à Prarayer,
à 2000m d'altitude, mais les plus importantes
sont celles de Saint-Gervais et de Briançon.
À la fin du Moyen Âge les villes ne cessent
de gonfler et donc d'importer des viandes
et produits laitiers. Cette forte demande
profite aux Alpes, qui se tournent vers un
élevage spécialisé à but commercial, mais
aussi à toute la Provence: de plus en plus
d'éleveurs des plaines louent des pâtures
en montagne pour prendre part à la transhumance,
et sont plus ou moins tolérés par les montagnards.
On parle d' «exode rural» pour désigner
la désertification des campagnes, mais contrairement
à ce qu'on pourrait croire, en montagne,
ces mouvements sont rarement définitifs.
Les montagnards pratiquent depuis longtemps
la migration saisonnière pendant l'hiver;
dans les hautes vallées du Queyras et du
Briançonnais, au XIIIe siècle, un tiers
des maisons reste occupé durant cette saison.
Certains paysans pratiquent la transhumance
inversée, allant faire pâturer leurs bêtes
dans les plaines durant l'hiver, partant soit
entre hommes soit avec leur famille entière.
Ceux qui ne gardent pas les animaux vont alors
mendier, glaner, ou se louer pour travailler
dans les champs, les mines, les ports... Ces
migrations montrent les difficultés de vivre
en montagne, surtout pendant l'hiver où tous
les travaux des champs sont interrompus. Ceux
qui restent travaillent dans l'artisanat ou
le textile...
-Certaines régions alpines se spécialisent:
c'est le cas des habitants de la Suisse centrale
qui se font mercenaires, au point de se retrouver
en 1500 dans une bataille où les soldats
des deux camps réalisent qu'ils viennent
des mêmes vallées. Ils fraternisent alors
et livrent l'un des chefs milanais au roi
de France.
-D'autres migrent définitivement, espérant
fuir leur misère en devenant domestiques
ou soldats. En s'enrichissant, grâce au commerce,
certaines familles montagnardes vont s'installer
dans les villes de la vallée telles que Grenoble.
Ces migrations ne sont pas le propre des montagnes:
l'exode rural existe dès le XVe siècle et
concerne les bretons, les picards... Tous
les habitants des campagnes, attirés par
les villes en pleine expansion. Pour autant,
les relations avec la montagne demeurent.
Certains anciens montagnards vont y chercher
leur femme, d'autres continuent de posséder
quelques terres. Certains y retournent aussi,
parce qu'ils ont échoué en ville ou par
nostalgie.
Au XIXe siècle, l'industrialisation renforce
cet exode mais facilite aussi les communications.
Le train arrive dans les montagnes de Savoie
en 1856. Les années 20 modifient encore la
vie en montagne, puisque l'essor du tourisme
entraîne l'installation de nouvelles populations,
des notables issus des villes et des entrepreneurs
venant investir dans l'hôtellerie.
Parce que oui, il faut bien en arriver à
ce moment où la montagne attire et éveille
la curiosité. A partir du XVIIIe siècle
des scientifiques se rendent sur les montagnes
pour étudier la géologie, la physique, la
chimie... Et puis rapidement, la montagne
se met à plaire pour son esthétique. Avec
l'influence des philosophes des Lumières
et du préromantisme, on se met à aimer la
nature, à vouloir explorer les derniers espaces
encore inconnus. C'est le premier mobile de
l'alpinisme qui apparaît à la fin du XVIIIe
siècle: atteindre un sommet vierge.
-Yond is what the lady hath said.
-La première ascension du Mont Blanc est
effectuée par deux montagnards en 1786, mais
l'histoire retient surtout celle du savant
Bénédicte de Saussure un an plus tard. Les
ascensions se popularisent dans toute l'Europe
mais restent un loisir de la bourgeoisie.
La visite des glaciers, la contemplation des
sites pittoresques devient le tourisme par
excellence du début du XIXe siècle. Les
anglais, surtout, gravissent plus du tiers
des sommets vierges européens et sont les
premiers à créer un Alpine club à Londres,
ville de montagne par excellence, en 1857.
La France conserve une approche plus scientifique
et culturelle: le Club Alpin Français,
fondé en 1874, publie énormément d'articles
scientifiques, littéraires ou artistiques
sur les montagnes et leur ascension.
Fréquenter les montagnes présente aussi
un intérêt sanitaire, les médecins du début
du XIXe siècle recommandent l'air de mer
ou d'altitude pour redonner de la vitalité
et fortifier les malades, notamment les tuberculeux.
Des sanatoriums ouvrent en montagne et proposent
à leurs patients de se promener sur les sentiers,
de profiter des forêts de pins ou de s'allonger
dans des galeries aérées et au soleil.
Au cours du XXe siècle, on en arrive à une
situation compliquée en montagne. Celles-ci
se dépeuplent de leurs habitants, mais sont
prises d'assaut par les stations de ski qui
se popularisent dans les années 60. A cette
époque on pense que la montagne est sauvée,
des emplois sont crées, un courant d'émigration
vers les montagnes apparaît, mais avec du
recul on constate que le solde migratoire
en montagne reste négatif. Les stations alpines
s'installent sur d'autres versants, ceux à
l'ombre, où la neige est plus abondante,
contrairement aux montagnards anciens qui
recherchaient justement tout le contraire.
La montagne se vide donc, et les parcs nationaux
crées au cours du XXe siècle symbolisent
bien ce territoire du vide: ce sont des
sanctuaires dans lesquels l'homme doit intervenir
le moins possible, alors qu'on a vu que ces
montagnes ont été profondément modifiées
et parcourues par les défricheurs du Moyen
Âge. André Micoud, sociologue, écrit:«Il
reste juste assez d’habitants dans le paysage,
[…] juste assez pour que le risque de dégradations
des patrimoines soit le plus faible possible,
pour que l’espace soit rendu possible aux
plaisirs des citadins, pour que la nature
ouvragée par des siècles de travail paysan
puisse encore être offerte aux contemplations
“ruralisantes” nostalgiques et aux spéculations
touristiques, pour que les derniers milieux
naturels restent encore accessibles aux observateurs
de la faune et de la flore.»
J'espère que cet épisode vous a plu, j'aime
beaucoup cette approche culturelle des liens
entre les hommes et un certain type de territoire
donc je me devais bien de faire la montagne
un jour.
La prochaine vidéo sera un Gentes Dames Badass,
sur une femme dont je n'ai pas encore décidé
de l'identité, alors en attendant vous pouvez
toujours rester chez vous tant que durera
le confinement et passer le temps en me tipant
sur Tipeee ou Utip. Si vous regardez cette
vidéo après le confinement, youpi, on s'en
est sortis. Si vous regardez cette vidéo
en tant que dernier survivant de l'humanité:
bravo à vous. Et à bientôt!